welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Loki season 2 had a special
presentation at d23 which actually had
some new footage unveiled exclusively to
attendees and putting the pieces
together we now know the opening
sequence of the Season confirmation on
what version of the TVA Loki ended up in
how the sacred timeline is actually
getting revenge against Sophie for her
first strike and how much of the season
will include Kang AKA Victor timely I'm
gonna break it all down as well as this
new Entertainment Weekly image of kiwi
Kwan as the TVA technician Obi Orr Oro
Boris because there are some clues in
this image that already began to explain
where things are headed to best prepare
for Loki season 2 we are in the middle
of a Loki season 1 rewatch where we are
discovering all kinds of new details
like did you know the Watergate tapes
are in that TBA drawer or that the Haven
Hills hurricane was actually a category
9 storm caused by two storms merging
destroying every Gulf Coast Community in
their wakes like Loki and Sylvie do yeah
a lot of cool stuff we missed the first
time around so give those videos a watch
okay this new footage is what I assume
is the opening sequence of the Season
unless there's like a flashback prologue
showing Victor timely's earlier years or
some other character but this sequence
begins where season one left off a
massive statue of Kang looming over the
TVA so we pull back through a window to
see Loki fleeing down a hall from Mobius
and the TBA Hunters they do not know who
he is because we saw with Mobius and B15
last season they didn't recognize Loki
so Loki goes up to a ledge and he Dives
out a window falling falling falling and
then Landing in the bed of a yellow
hover truck it kind of reminds us of
lilu's Escape in The Fifth Element
Landing in Corbin Dallas is taxi but the
driver of this yellow truck freaks out
and it steers into the statue of Kang
cutting it on its cheek which kind of
feels like a foreshadowing wound that
the character of Kang over he remains
might suffer in real life in the course
of the series especially considering the
three leaders of the Kang Dynasty and
mortis Pharaoh Rama touch and Scarlet
Centurion whom we saw in the quantum
media post-credits scene all had
interesting anatomies and bodily wounds
and markings on their faces real quick
we want to thank bloodline Heroes of
lythus for sponsoring this video
bloodline is a fantasy RPG where you
create Legendary Champions by combining
the Bloodlines of elves demons Orcs
lichens and more to build your kingdom
it's absolutely free to play download it
now using the link in the description or
scan the QR code bloodline currently has
over 4 000 Champion hybrid options for
you to create by marrying Bloodlines it
introduces new Bloodlines every two
weeks so there's always something new to
do the newest bloodline are the tide
razors which are demigods of the sea but
my favorite are the novella ruthless
assassins who became vampires after a
cursed ritual gave them a hunger for
blood they're perfect champions for the
fall I'm also a sucker for lion Stone
particularly with the new futuristic
looking skin I love it there's a ton of
depth and strategy in bloodline and the
mixing of Bloodlines gives you a ton of
options of how to build your team the
game has incredible graphics and it's
designed to give you AAA visual
experience on your smartphone or your
tablet to get started on a kingdom of
your own use the link in the description
to download bloodline Heroes of lithus
for free on Android and iOS or scan a QR
code using that link will get you a
special starter pack worth twenty
dollars with one summoning Crystal 100
000 gold and 100 000 diamonds as an
added bonus the first 30 players to
reply to the pin comment with their
account ID and their username will
receive a free succubus so don't wait so
this truck crashes into another building
with Casey in it wearing headphones and
Loki spills out into this office and
Casey does not recognize him and calls
for security but then Loki looks down at
marble floor and he sees the TVA Crest
with the shield and the sword which had
been damaged in the result of this crash
but then Loki experiences some time
slipping he's now standing in front of
Casey in a later moment when Casey knows
who he is and the TVA Crest is still
damaged year but Casey can't remember of
a time when the damage wasn't there so
Loki assumes from this that before he
was just in the past before he met any
of these people so Loki Time Slips again
and he appears in a room with another
Loki but when that Loki turns to look
our Loki Time Slips Away again now this
Loki could be from Loki episode 2 in
season 1 when he started wearing that
variant jacket or he could be a Loki a
little bit further ahead from our Loki
is now and add a couple episodes from
now we're gonna loop back on this moment
so from all this we can assume that the
version of the TBA with Kang as a big
statue in place of the three timekeepers
is really a past time period in the
tva's history and that in that period
Kang openly lorded over the TBA but then
some event changed that and caused Kang
to decide to hide and run the TVA from
the Shadows using the three timekeepers
as his puppets and I'm guessing that
event is connected to the breaking of
that fourth timekeeper statue in the
Citadel and the Loki finale episode
perhaps the event was some kind of
revolt against Kang maybe a Lover's
dispute between him and ranslayer she
might have been that fourth timekeeper
and she could have led the rest of the
TDA Rank and file to overturn the boss
and then at King in response to this
reset everything so that everyone's
memories was wiped and that instead of
one dictatorial boss there is three
sacred time Keepers that could have been
the point where Ms minutes decided to
compose that TVA narrative commission
propaganda video that we saw in Loki
episode one so Loki's time slipping in
other words going back and forth within
one timeline gives him an accidental
Advantage here and yes we should note
that this means that the TVA does
actually progress in time on its own
path for Loki to Jump Ahead or jump
backward within that path but it also
means that whatever the secrets Kang he
remains or Miss minutes are hiding from
the TVA Employees those are all now
discoverable by Loki accidentally time
slipping to a pass before any of the
resets happened this d23 footage also
includes existing trailer footage that's
been re-cut like Loki and Mobius and
tuxedos and an alley outside that zaniac
movie premiere with Loki duplication
casting himself and Sylvie after a shift
working in McDonald's in Brooklyn 1982
when she goes to a record store and goes
to her home and we see how the room is
unwinding around her and now when we see
it in the footage it actually kind of
feels like the sacred timeline is
attacking her like getting back at her
or disrupting it in the season one
finale it actually kind of feels like a
literal version of what Tony Stark said
in Avengers end game you mess with time
it tends to match back I just love this
idea of the Sacred timeline possessing
its own sentience outside of Kang and
his variance attempts to manipulate it
kind of like the way Elias is a sentient
creature that Kang was able to tame
since Goliath is kind of like
anti-matter maybe the opposite of
eliaith which would be flowing time and
all of matter is another kind of entity
that the kangs are in kind of a dance
with an entity capable of Revenge an
entity like Eon which is the Marvel
deity that represents time we actually
saw its head in Thor love and thunder in
this d23 footage we hear voice over from
Loki as he warns Sylvie that he's seen
visions of the future and that if
something doesn't change the universe
will be completely destroyed now we also
got an update from The Hollywood
Reporter about Jonathan Major's legal
issues that stated the actor was
believed to appear in about half of the
episodes of Loki season 2. now season
two is going to be six episodes we're
talking about three episodes okay it
might break down the latest trailer last
week I discovered Victor timely in the
background of a shot showing Mobius and
Loki's plan to send Mobius down that
catwalk toward the disrupted TVA
temporal core this means that the good
guys will be teaming up with his past
version of Kang and that Victor timely
is actually going to set foot inside of
the TVA to help them Entertainment
Weekly also did this fun write-up of
kiwi Kwan's character OB executive
producer Kevin Wright said quote his job
is basically every piece of tech every
computer everything that is running the
TVA he either designed it or he fixes it
and keeps it running this new image that
they shared shows the bottom half of a
shot that we started to see in the July
trailer Loki and Mobius Pier over the
counter and now we see OB wiring
together this piece of technology this
device is extremely important it's the
same one that Moby's carries in other
images we also saw him holding it in the
July trailer and he definitely has this
with him as he heads out toward the
temporal core in the radiation suit so
what is this thing it kind of looks like
Rick together pieces of the temporal
Marvel that Victor timely is showing off
at the World's Fair maybe that's why
they need him because he has the
original blueprints of it but I'm
guessing it's kind of a patch to fix the
timeline braiding process in this broken
temporal core and on the label of that
device you can barely make out the words
at the top of it TDA property also on
the shelves behind OB are various
vintage electronics and Hardware
packages from The Real World like a box
reading mullard which is a British
Electronics components manufacturer that
formed in 1920 on the right side of OB
are some cans for something for Cycles
cars and side cars and then there's a
big orange binder or kind of box
container with a label on the side with
the TVA logo and Crest the question I
have for OB is was he the one who
designed that TVA training module that
used the multiple choice question about
Thanos eating apples because the wording
of this question I think is the most
fascinating detail of Loki and I went
deep into it in our episode 2
re-breakdown so please check out our
Loki re-watches you know what hold on to
your butts for a wild season of Loki and
in-depth Easter egg breakdowns here on
new rock stars please subscribe to all
three channels in the new rockstars
Network you can follow me on all social
platforms that eat a boss thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
y'all
[Music]
thank you